well hey you guys uh here I am once
again doing a movie review all by myself
hopefully you guys can hear me let me
check the microphone there we go
everything is fine as I mentioned before
um I keep forgetting to Port the little
intros that I would have normally put on
my recorded flickers of fear and Toes of
Terror shows um I forgot to Port them
over to this computer and put them in
OBS so that's why this one that's why
these live streams don't even have an
intro and I'm just kind of like n I'm
just too lazy to do it I guess I just
keep forgetting and then I get over here
and get started and I'm just kind of
like ah never mind it's not really that
big of a deal so I'm just like not going
to worry about it but yeah so we're
doing another movie review today this
was a movie that I just watched
yesterday that I'd actually been wanting
to see for a pretty long time uh before
we get into it though uh let me mention
the sponsor of this little show here
which today is audible uh most people
know what audible is it is the largest
one of the largest if not the largest uh
Repository of audiobooks and podcasts in
the whole entire world they have pretty
much anything that you would want to
listen to on there and if you click the
link in the description box right now uh
you will get a 30-day free trial of
audible and which means that for 30 days
you can read listen to anything that you
want on their site uh with not using any
points and also you get um one credit to
use on anything that you want on the
site and you can keep that forever if
you're already an Amazon Prime member
then you actually get two credits that
you can use on the site and again you
can keep whatever you buy forever but
like I said this 30-day free trial it's
a really good deal they have a bunch of
stuff 30 days is a long time you can
listen to a lot of stuff on there
without having to pay a penny which is
like really really cool so yeah if you
click the link down in the description
box you will get all that uh full
disclosure I also get a small commission
whenever somebody uh signs up through
that link but if you would do that it's
would support the show very much so I
appreciate it so let's talk about Ponty
pool now I had forgotten how old this
movie
is well I guess like you know it's 2008
which doesn't seem that old but it is it
was a long time ago so this movie it's
one that I just kept seeing it turn up
on different internet lists of like
underrated horror movies and you know if
you're sick of zombie movies this is
kind of like a zombie movie but not like
it's a really good idea and stuff like
that and so I kind of read a little
sentence about it like I didn't really
read a lot about it but just kind of the
one sentence synopsis or whatever and I
said well that sounds actually pretty
interesting so I had kind of been
wanting to see it like lowkey on the
back burner but for some reason I just
never got around to it but then a couple
days ago I was scrolling through the new
additions on shudder and I saw that they
had added it and I was like oh I got to
do a stream about that because finally I
can pull the trigger on this because
I've wed to see it for a long time and
there it is so as I mentioned this came
out in
2008 and it's actually
Canadian and I'm going to say this is a
really good this movie is a really good
example
of how you do like a high concept on a
really really low budget uh for another
Stellar example of this please see the
movie coherence which I think came out
in 2015 or 2016 uh that was another one
that was just shot in the director's
house or for almost nothing and it's
great uh but it's ALS it's like really
it's like Cosmic this one is not quite
like that um and it takes place pretty
much like allinone location for the most
part but like I said this is kind of how
you do something like this right I feel
like if you don't have a big budget to
start with particularly in horror then
just kind of use that as an impetus to
make the story better don't try to be
too big for your Brites I guess like
don't try to like do this big epic kind
of [__] when you can't afford it because
if you just try to cheap out on it's
going to look like crap um I so I prefer
that if you don't have a high budget
that you just kind of take what you do
have the take take the limitations that
you have and like make a story that will
work in those within those parameters
and that's definitely what they did with
Pony pool now this is actually I didn't
know this when I saw it but I found out
later on this is actually based on a
novel from
1995 uh which was called Ponty pool
changes everything and it's by Tony
Burgess not Anthony Burgess that's a
completely different guy the guy that
wrote clock orang Tony Burgess um and he
actually also adapted his own book like
for the screenplay of this movie which I
thought was pretty cool so the movie
it's kind of
like um like an
apocalyptic infection style horror it
usually gets called a zombie movie which
which I guess it kind of is but not
really it's kind of zombie adjacent but
it's not like exactly the same thing and
it has like this really interesting
angle like this really reason for the
really good reason for the infection
that you don't really see much if at all
like in the sub genre so it's like
really unique in that regard also has
like a really really small cast and this
really kind of I get like claustrophobic
setting that really barely shows what's
going on out inside the building where
all of the action takes place but it
sort of conveys almost all the events of
the story through dialogue so it's kind
of like a radio drama and matter of fact
I think they did do a radio drama
version of it like on the BBC like
either the same year or the year after
it came out so it works uh in that
context as well and particularly because
and it's almost kind of like meta that
they do that because the whole uh
premise the movie has to do with sound
words language things like that so I
thought it was kind of cool that they
sort of you know had had that kind of
thematic resonance going with it where
you know they're like oh well we're
going to make it like a radio play kind
of you know what I mean um yeah Hugo
said saw along time ago unforeseen said
this is one of those movies that was
released around the same time as another
movie with a very similar concept dead
air with Bill Mosley oh you know what I
have never seen that one I kind of feel
like I don't know I wrote a short story
a long time AG that wasn't exactly like
a word virus but kind of and I don't
even remember I know that I wrote that
story like before this movie came out
because I know I you know what I mean
and I hadn't seen this I didn't see this
movie until yesterday anyway so I didn't
get the idea from there I don't even
remember where I got the idea from but I
wrote a story a long time ago called
lepidoptera that was um that was kind of
similar in the sense that it was just
like a word that triggered like a a
physical like viral reaction kind of
thing so that was kind of what I thought
of like when I first saw this movie
mov um but yeah so this movie has the
great wonderful Steven Maca in it who's
in tons of stuff um but I recognized him
from secretary which [__] I got to do a
review on that one it's not a horror
movie but I love that [__] movie like
with um Maggie Gyllenhaal and uh James
Spader it was really really good he was
in History of Violence the David kenberg
movie he was in a movie called Haunter
with Abigail bresin
which when the hell did that come out
2016 I want to say that was actually
pretty good too I don't know if I did a
review of it but I wrote about it on my
blog like a long time ago because I just
kind of came across it randomly uh and
that's really good it's kind of like a
Time Loop kind of um movie and uh he was
also inum to Daddy which I think we did
review not too long ago that has
um what's that dude's name now I can't
think of that actor's name that was in
come to Daddy I think that came out in
2019 but we we did a review of it like
last year something like that but he was
in that too so yeah so Stephen MCAT is
in this and he
plays this kind of I want to say shock
jock type like talk radio host even
though he's not that shocking especially
compared to like the stupid [__] people
say online nowadays it seemed pretty
mild um but yeah so so he's this radio
host now the implication is I gu they
don't I don't think they even say this
outright but the implication is that he
was fired from like his last on air gig
supposedly for saying some too shocking
things and they're just like yeah you
get out of here so he gets a job at this
sort of tiny radio station called clsy
which is in this little rural town of
ponti pool in Ontario Canada which
apparently is a real town I don't know
how big it is it's funny because the
first time that I heard about this movie
I thought it was a Welsh movie because
there's also a town in Wales called
Ponty pool and I was a lot more familiar
with that so I was like oo a Welsh movie
but then I was like oh it's Canada I
guess they have a ponti pool in Canada
too but yeah so that's it so kind of
confused me for a little while but
that's neither here nor there so at the
very beginning of the movie um you have
this really good scene which is like
this really eerie foreshadowing right of
what's to come I guess so Grant which is
the name of the the guy Grant Mazy is
his name um he's driving to work in the
morning and it's still dark out and it's
snowing since winter time I think it's
Valentine's Day actually because I think
they do mention that he brings
Valentine's and stuff but yeah it's
Valentine's Day so it's freezing cold
and he's kind of driving through the
snow and the dark and everything and he
stops at a stop sign or red light or
whatever and he sees this like scared
looking woman like this young woman who
doesn't really look like she's dressed
for the weather going to say I don't
know if they even bring anything up
about about that but she's kind of
standing outside his passenger side
window like with her hand on it like
kind of banging on it a little bit and
she's
repeating a word and I'm pretty sure she
says blood like over and over again um
and he's just like wait what like what
are you talking about and he doesn't
know what the deal is and then she just
kind of you know vanishes back into the
snow and he has this kind of Crisis over
whether he should call 911 about it and
that's like one of the things that he
talks about like when he gets to the
radio station and like starts talking on
air you know what I mean like when do
you call 911 and maybe we need this
other number that's like not quite an
emergency but maybe something [__] up
is going on so you know maybe it should
be like 912 or something you know so
there's that whole
conversation so when he gets to the
station he um kind of says hi to his two
co-workers now one of them is this
younger woman and she's I guess she's
like the technical assistant and she's
also a military veteran they bring up
that she was at in Afghanistan and her
name is Laurel Anne and then there's
this kind of the producer of the show
who's this kind of noons slightly older
woman probably in her 30s I imagine um
whose name is
Sydney now Laurel an seems kind of
amused by Grant's kind of crotchety
dickish on air personality like the
shenanigans like I said it's not overthe
toop it's not like [__] like it's not
like Howard Stern or like some stupid
[__] nowadays but you know it's pretty
mild as far as that goes but you know
he's still kind of being a little bit of
a dick just a little bit but she seems
to think it's kind of funny but cydney
who's the producer she's getting real
exasperated and she just like wants him
to stop stirring the [__] and just you
know why don't you just do your job and
like tell our listeners about school
closures and traffic updates and [__]
like that that they actually need to
know about right and he's just just like
more you know and he's gets kind of
cranky about it but I mean it is his job
so he very
grudgingly says he's going to do it okay
but he's like I said he's grumbling
about it however not too long into the
shift it seems that something kind of
weird might be going on in ponti
pool now while they're getting the live
weather and traffic report from Ken
Looney their field guy I guess um who
this is actually funny because he
supposedly flying around in the sunshine
Chopper which is like the helicopter
that this radio station supposedly has
like to do the weather and the traffic
and stuff but then later on you find out
it's like we don't have a chopper um
he's just sitting like on a high Hilltop
like in his old Dodge Dart like looking
down over the city and that's how he
does the reports it's like it just makes
other people feel better to think that
there's like a sunshine there's like a
helicopter we're keeping track of
everything you know what I mean we're
watching you but uh but yeah so I
thought that was pretty funny so Ken in
his dodged art um he tells the gang back
at
clsy that he's seeing some pretty weird
[__] starting to go down he says there's
a bunch of towns people that have come
like busting out or like exploding out
of the side of a building like I guess
they're all like leaning on it which I
mean you can't see it cuz it's all audio
like it comes over the the is talking
about it but I'm guessing that they were
all like pushing against this wall until
it finally like busted out and then they
came out like that so the building that
they have come busting out of is the
office of a doctor named Dr
Mendes and he says now the people have
all come busting out and then they seem
to be engaged in some kind of Riot uh
the purpose of which is not super
clear hey Tom what are you doing point
the camera look at him he comes in and
he's comes in the chat room and he's
like [__] with my [__] I can't even
like be in the room he's in the other
room doing it Tom's got to he's got to
be the manager from the from the other
room I see you I see you in there I mean
you can come on and be on the show if
you want it's allowed it's
allowed um somebody was in uh yeah I
mentioned that he was in uh History of
Violence was it Robert
Patrick in this movie no it was Stephen
MCA they do slightly look alike though
especially when they got older so I can
see how you would think that because
they do kind of look
like but yeah moderator and director I
know that's like it's [__] funny um
yeah it's find the audio adaptation and
Curl Up On a Winter's Night yeah that's
what I was thinking because I didn't
know like until after I watched the
movie that this was also presented as a
radio drama it's much shorter than the
movie I think the radio play is only an
hour and the movie is like about an hour
and a half hour and 35 minutes something
like that so they did cut some stuff out
and I think the ending is different but
I can totally see how this would work
like a just like an audio drama it's
like really cool Zach says Tom's like
the male version of the momager from
hell he is kind of that is like I looked
over and saw his little icon and I'm
like oh man that's like so funny now I'm
all like now I'm all like self-conscious
[Laughter]
he said pokey's [__] up all the CDs
in the cabinet yeah she does that she
must want
something but uh but yeah so where was I
all right so um so yeah so Ken in the
Dodge Dart he said I saw all these
people come busting out of the side of
this building and he's like and it's
crazy it looks crazy it looks like
they're having a riot I don't know what
the [__] is going on now so they kind of
they don't get any official
confirmation of this incident like from
the police or the authorities or
anything like that so Sydney who's the
producer she's like well she tells Grant
well you better just keep your mouth
shut about it until we can figure out
what's going on because we don't want to
be irresponsible and Report you know
mistaken information like if we don't
know what's going on because the cops
are clearly not there yet and we don't
know what all the details are we're just
taking Ken's word for it and you know
and he's just talking about it we don't
know what's going
on so But as time goes on though like
Ken's
reports start getting kind of weirder
and more horrific and then at that point
Grant starts to think maybe they're all
being punked like maybe he's playing a
prank on them or cuz he's it's implied
that he's relatively new to this station
and he's kind of I don't know if I want
to say he's famous famous but they do
imply that he's kind of welln at least
in radio circles talk radio circles and
so he's thinking that maybe I came to
this little town and people are like
[__] with me so he's like maybe you
guys all got together and decided to do
this prank you know what I mean so
you're calling in like all this crazy
[__] like to make me look stupid or
something like that so he's thinking
along those lines so at some point the
three of them at the radio station they
lose their connection with Ken for a
little while and there are some other
Witnesses like neighbors and stuff that
call into the the station to like try
and help out and like describe what
they're seeing but all of them get cut
off or they hang up or something like
that before they can give them any
verifiable information right and then
there's this creepy message in
French that inserts itself into the
radio broadcast from somewhere like they
don't know how it got in there and then
when Laurel Anne translates it like
using Google or whatever it seems kind
of nonsensical a little bit but it also
specifically warns them not to translate
the message from French into English Eng
and say it over the radio so whoops too
late yeah so that uh turns out badly you
find out why like later
on um yeah Tom says I'm watching
you that was like creeping
me Every Breath You Take that's what
he's doing yeah he's just like watching
me all the time uh where does this film
take place at in a little in a Canadian
it's in Ontario like a little Canadian
town called ponti pool which is appar
like I said is a real place um isn't
some Willie Willie defo look William
defo lookalike in this movie well if you
think that Stephen MCA looks like
William defo which I guess he kind of
does like I said he kind of looks like
Robert Patrick too now that I'm thinking
about it all those kind of character
actors all looks look sort of the same
but yeah he's kind of like I said I've
seen Stephen MCAT in a lot of things I
think he is a Canadian actor now that
I'm thinking about it and uh that's why
he was in some kerberg flicks and stuff
but yeah he does kind of look like he
has that real like rugged
looking face that a lot of those kind of
character actors have so I can see how
he's easily confused with other actors
and he plays kind of
a I don't know I like the role that he
plays in this he's kind of it's not
crazy like I said he's kind of like a
like mildly assholish but not like over
the top but I don't know he kind of goes
on these sort of rants like later on
that I kind of enjoyed but you know what
I mean
yeah Tom said uh looks good camera
lighting is good well I didn't change
the lighting that's what I mean although
I almost left that bathroom light on in
there because I forgot that it was on
because I was over there making some
making some iced coffee for the show and
then I where the coffee pot is I forgot
to turn the light off and um yeah okay
so so there's this whole thing so
they've translated the French message
into English you know at the very end it
said please do not translate this into
English and they're just like oh and
then we said it out loud okay now
meanwhile after all that happens Ken in
the Dodge Dart he is actually able to
get in contact with the station again
like over the phone and he tells them
that the town's people are going crazy
and he's hiding out in a grain silo like
he's hiding in there and he can like see
them like through the crack but they
don't can't see him so he's obviously
[__] his pants in Terror as you
probably would be and he starts
describing he's like the people are
chanting like meaningless words and
phrases over and over again and he's
like some of them have like torn people
apart like fresh bread and also looks
like some of them are like eating each
other there's like cannibalism that's I
kind of think that's why some people
categorize this as a zombie film I don't
know like I said I guess you could call
it a zombie film I guess the people are
technically zombies but it's not really
they're not Undead and they're not
shambling it's not exactly the same you
know what I mean like I said it's zombie
adjacent but it's not really you know
it's not like reanimated corpses or
anything like that now at this point so
they hear this
craziness and um the three of them at
the radio station but they're still not
getting like any official news about the
outbreak which is you know coming over
the the wire or whatever so they aren't
entirely sure what to believe there's
like there's still a possibility that
this is just all like an elaborate prank
you know why would anybody pull a prank
like this we don't know but it's like
you know maybe that's what it is but
they can't find anything about it online
anywhere now they do at some point
shortly after this they do get an
official declaration that ponti pool is
now under quarantine but that's pretty
much like all the detail that they're
given right so they're just kind of like
okay well I guess maybe something is
going on they just don't know what it is
exactly so then they get a phone call
from this like high Mucky muck dude like
reporter at the BBC
and he calls the station to get a
firsthand report because apparently
rumors about this crazy series of events
have already traveled all the way across
the Atlantic and they're just like what
the hell is going on over there we heard
in this small town like everybody's gone
crazy and they're rioting and stuff and
eating each other so Grant is like
doesn't really know what to tell the guy
because they don't really have any idea
what's going on themselves all they
really have is like Ken's word for it
and a couple like weird anomalies that
have been going on but the BBC anchor
guy keeps trying to tie the incident in
with like separatist
terrorists and he keeps reporting the
event in those terms even after Grant
specifically tells him look that's
probably not what's going on here this
seems like much weirder but you know the
BBC guy keeps saying that that's like
what the reason for it is and then like
later on they see kind of like a news
broadcast from the BBC where they're
kind of saying that they think that that
might be the reason for the rioting
right even though it's obviously not so
not too long after that um Grant who is
very frustrated and very angry at this
point um he attempts to leave the
station pretty much still thinking this
entire situation is just a hoax and then
like the people are [__] with him you
know what I mean but this Theory gets
shot down pretty quickly when a bunch of
Ponty pool residents kind of gather
around outside the radio station and
they're like banging to be let in kind
of like zombies um but they keep
repeating the people's words like back
to them like over and over again like
they you know the just [__] they say and
then like all the people out there just
start repeating it you know what I mean
which is a little bit freaky it's a
little bit
freaky so then Laurel Anne the youngest
girl the um the technical assistant she
starts to show symptoms of whatever the
[__] is taking over the towns people
like in her case she starts talking in
these really roundabout like gibberish
phrases almost like it sounds like
somebody like maybe having a stroke like
she sounds a little bit like that like
she'll say something that sounds like a
sentence but it doesn't make any sense
in context and then she keeps repeating
words like endlessly and you know
repeating words that sound like those
words and then repeating that you know
what I mean and then she kind of goes in
the other room and like kind of stands
her with her head cocked over to the
side and making this really weird like
high pitched
almost like a singing kind of noise but
it's just like one note again it's like
really creepy so that happens and then
Dr Mendes who the guy from the beginning
who we this is the first time we've seen
him though but you just heard about him
before like it was his office that all
the people busted out of and so Dr
Mendes actually comes climbing in the
window of the radio station and he's
like yeah I've been running for these
people all day like he escaped the riot
that was at his office he got the hell
out of there and he's just been like
kind of trying to make his way to the
radio station so he can kind of hole up
there with them because he knows they're
still there because he's been listening
so he's not entirely sure what's going
on either but he has seen a bunch of
these infected people and his theory is
that the people of ponti pool are
succumbing to some kind of virus that
makes them violent and murderous and
cannibalistic um but
that this virus is not a regular virus
like it's not translated through like um
you know transmitted through the air or
through blood or anything like that but
is transmitted through certain
words now he's also figured out that the
virus is only present in English uh
which leads some of the characters later
on to try to communicate in other
languages like French or Armenian
because the doctor's Armenian um to kind
of avoid spreading it further that's
kind of why that message broke through
in French that said don't translate this
into English because the virus is only
present in English if you talk to a in a
different language then apparently it
can't spread so there's that um look at
Tom where the super chat's at he's in
the he's in the chat like passing the
passing the hat
around that's what I I really I
appreciate that Tom I appreciate you
showing
up oh and he's talking about his nuts
too even when he's in the other room he
can't resist like talking about talking
about his nuts uh but yeah so yeah
basically this is a zombie movie but the
transmission of the virus is through
language like through Words which like I
said is a pretty odd premise um but it's
pretty unique to be sure uh you don't
really see this in other zombie movies
um and I have to say that it having a
premise like that I think it has a lot
to play with like
thematically CU it kind of says a lot
about um like The Power of Words the
power of
communication um and the way that using
the wrong words or spreading
misinformation can cause chaos you know
what I mean it's not super heavy-handed
with that message but it's there like
you know like I said thematically like
kind of underlying the whole thing um
like at the beginning of the story for
example Grant is kind of very much in
that shock jock mindset um you know he
even has a little small little argument
with Sydney about this at the beginning
because she's just like hey why don't
you just do your job and tell people
what the traffic is and where the school
closures are and [__] like that instead
of [__] around and he's like well you
know I have to say outrageous things
because I need to Foster anger in my
listeners because then my listeners will
share their outrage with others and more
people will listen because that's what
people want to listen to they want to be
angry they want to be outraged and so
he's trying to stir the [__] you know
what I mean to get people to listen and
get people to pay attention um but as
The Story Goes
On he seems to like start to
realize the one like the importance of
imparting truth and not fear mogging and
like trying to outrage people just for
the sake of outraging them and maybe too
that sometimes silence is the best
course of action that's why I think the
um the tagline of the movie is like
something like shut up or die or
something like that which is kind of
dumb but it's like it kind of goes along
with the with the movie because the
movie is actually a lot smarter and like
more intellectual than that I kind of
feel like the tagline makes it sound
like a dumb horror comedy which it
absolutely isn't Now Grant eventually
kind of comes to the Revelation in fact
that him just kind of carelessly
pursuing controversy like for the sake
of controvers or for the sake of getting
listeners may have actually been a
significant factor in the spread of this
word virus in ponti pool like he I don't
he's not like patient zero or anything
like that but he's kind of like one that
maybe helped it spread further than it
would have because of [__] that he said
on the radio you know what I mean so he
kind of comes to that realization too
now I'm going to say that the movie it
gets a little bit more
abstract after Laurel an um kind of
succumbs to the virus and starts acting
crazy and banging her head against the
wall and [__] like that and Grant comes
to the conclusion that the only way that
you can break the virus's hold on your
mind is by
essentially making yourself uner
understand the particular word that
infected you because I guess it's a
different word for everybody so whatever
word it was that caus the virus to take
your mind over you almost have to kind
of go back and deliberately not
understand that word anymore and I think
they don't go really into this but the
implication I got or this is how I read
it was that it seemed like some of the
people that were infected with the virus
like they knew that
instinctively and that's why they kept
desperately trying to repeat words over
and over because you know if you repeat
a word over and over like it loses its
meaning and so they were trying to do
that like they were trying to like break
the viruses hold on them but it wasn't
working um so they did seem to have and
I think Dr Mendes even compared that to
an immune response um you know just
repeating the words over and over
because that's what a lot of them were
doing but it turns out that the real
cure if indeed that is what it is
because they kind of leave it ambiguous
as to whether it worked like over the
long term or not um The Cure is actually
not in sort of like losing the meaning
of the words by repeating them but in by
but by like redefining them I guess like
Grant ends up cuz Sydney actually starts
showing symptoms of the virus
too and Grant apparently cures her by
replacing her trigger word which is kill
um with kiss instead and like trying
every time she says a word like he's
like this is this and he's like like a
completely different word that doesn't
have anything to do with that so once
Grant and Sydney like have figured this
out that this is maybe will work they
they're like we have to go back on the
error and help people because maybe this
will I mean at this point
most of the people in town are dead cuz
they've like killed each other because
like I said the virus kind of makes you
murderous and a lot of them like seem to
kill their own family members and stuff
they don't show any of this you just
know you just know it because of like
through the audio reports and stuff like
that so they kind of go on the radio um
to see if they can help the remaining
people but it seems like at this point
that it's kind of already too late like
even if it did work then it's just too
late to save everybody like I said
pretty much everybody and pontile is
dead at this point um at least that was
the implication so I'm going to say now
the concept of this movie is admittedly
a
little abstruse let's put it that way um
I did see because I was reading some of
the reviews on shudder and elsewhere and
stuff like that this is either one of
those movies that you're really really
going to dig it or some people were just
like I don't get it or I don't like it
it's too pretentious I didn't find it
pretentious particularly but keep in
mind
that it is like a radio drama it all
takes place in one room there's really
only three or four characters um you
don't there's hardly any Gore you don't
see anything happen you're just hearing
about it like you were listening to it
on the radio or like on on a podcast or
something but I mean in spite of that
it's like I've thought the concept of a
virus which is spread by words is that's
a pretty cool concept and it's really
like a
metaphorically written
area for a horror movie to explore I
think like there's a lot you could do
with that now I will say that this does
have a post credit scene that's a little
baffling uh it makes more sense in light
of something else that I'll be talking
about later on um and like I said the
movie is pretty light on Gore light on
violence um at least what's shown on
screen you don't really see much other
than Laurel an um you know getting
infected with the virus and kind of
[__] herself up like smashing her
face into the glass of the sound booth
and stuff like that you don't really see
any Gore or any violence it's all H you
just hear what's happening like people
are reporting it um but other than that
I mean I found this like a really tense
um very well acted kind of a
philosophical horror I want to say um
and I think it kind of used this kind of
real closed in setting that it had cuz
it's winter time you can't go it's all
this snow and they're just in this tiny
you know radio station and
you know and because there's not that
many people in the cast and it's just
this tiny place and they're all kind of
crammed in there I think it kind of used
that to maximum Effectiveness you know
it's like I said so it plays out like an
old timey radio drama like just kind of
just like War of the World so the ORS
and Wells kind of thing where it's like
you know I'm on the street and this is
happening and this is [__] up and oh
my God you know it's kind of that kind
of thing so I thought that was kind of a
cool and I and I think that um the
director Bruce McDonald he did um
deliberately want to make something like
that except like in movie form you know
what I mean so there are visuals to this
but it mostly plays out as an audio play
so as I mentioned and somebody mentioned
this earlier in the chat was that this
was actually presented in a slightly
different version as a BBC Radio play it
was about half an hour shorter and I
think the ending was a little bit
different um but it was kind of but I
thought that was kind of a cool concept
you don't really see much of that
anymore so in 2019 um the same director
who as as I mentioned was Bruce McDonald
he released this spin-off fantasy movie
called
Dreamland and that also had Stephen
macca in it um playing the alter ego
character that he appeared in as in
ponti pool at in the end credit sequence
that I said was kind of baffling because
like the there's credits and then
there's this weird sequence with him and
Sydney but they're like they have
different names and they look like old
timey like from the 20s or something and
I'm just like what the hell is that all
about but I guess it ties in with the
next movie which is Dreamland so his
character's name his alter ego is named
Johnny dead eyes now I haven't seen
Dreamland uh it seems a little bit hard
to get hold of from what I could
determine but from the synopsis of it it
seems to be an entirely different story
than ponti pool it doesn't have anything
to do with the zombie word virus or
anything like that but there's a vampire
in it and I think Stephen MCAT plays
like a dual role like he plays this jazz
musician and then he also plays kind of
this hardboiled Hitman who's been hired
to kill this jazz musician or cut off
his finger I can't remember but it's one
of those two things so it doesn't have
anything to do with the story so it's
almost kind of like like I said it's
more of a spin-off or like in the same
universe I guess and not a continuation
of Ponty pool you know what I
mean um Zak says that's a new word LOL
what is
uh well let me see because I got behind
a little bit on the
comments um Ben says I quite like Bill
Bailey's zombie film portrait of the
zombie as a young man oh I don't think
I've ever seen that uh and I like the
crazies remake I like the original
Crazies it's not fantastic I've heard
that the Remake is actually not bad and
I've been wanting to do a review of that
for a while but we'll see how it
goes um yeah it's a mockumentary about
the Discrimination faced by a family
because their son is a zombie oh that
sounds great actually actually it almost
kind of sounds like what was that other
like that zombie comedy uh Pho the one
that had Billy Connelly in it that was
kind of like an old school it was that
set in the 50s like in an alternate 50s
like in a Leave it to Beaver type world
that was like that was great I might
have done a review of that but I the
best description of Pho that I ever
heard was I think that came out in the
90s or early 2000s uh was if George A
Romero had directed Pleasantville and I
was like yeah nailed it
um but yeah it that was a great [__]
movie um let's see Danny says 2004
zombie honeymoon is pretty good and
original zombie flick yeah it's like I
kind of I like zombie movies don't get
me wrong but there's so many of them I
mean they're just they're so easy to do
they're easy to do they're cheap to film
and you know it's a
pretty it's it's a monster that can be
used like in a lot of different ways you
can make fast ones you can make slow
ones it's like these ones are Undead
these ones are alive you know what I
mean so you can there's a lot you can do
with it so I kind of got sick of them
but like I said every now and then you
come up with a good concept and this
even though I don't think I would call
it a zombie movie it's other people have
called ponti pool a zombie movie and
okay fair enough I see where they're
coming from with that um it doesn't seem
like a zombie movie to me
but I mean if it is a zombie movie then
it's one with like a really original uh
premise you know and um let's see
unforeseen said when it comes to 70s
infected rage style horror movies I much
pref for Berg's rabid over the crazies I
agree uh I do like Romero's crazies um
but I mean I'm a kernberg fan all day
and rabid is good honestly I just did a
review of the remake of rabid that the
Sasa sisters did which was actually I
was expecting it to suck out loud but it
was actually like it was actually pretty
good they did like something different
is there nudity in this film there is
not there is no nudity uh there's very
very little or very little violence like
I said it's almost like an audio drama
so uh let's see have I seen the signal
yes um and it's really really good I
don't think I I've reviewed it though so
maybe I'll put put that on my list and
like do that pretty soon because i' I've
been wanting to do that oh Zach says
AB I'm a Walkin thesaurus [__] you just
know know what I mean I was that I was
that girl in school like in the English
class that aced all the vocabulary tests
without even having to look anything up
because I learned to read when I was
real young and I used to just read
everything I was a voracious reader and
um so I just knew all kind of words they
like you know what I mean because I I
love words that's kind of I think that's
kind of why I was fascinated by the
premise of this movie because it's like
such a great it's just such a great
premise uh unforeseen said oh yeah phto
Billy Connelly is the pet
zombie um yeah the saskas are kinberg
inspired for sure yeah and even in the
Rabid remake they even put a little
shout out to dead Ringers in there which
I appreciated because man I love dead
ringers I was even thinking the other
day I was like oh [__] what a great
Halloween costume that would be if you
had a twin like don't just don't just do
the sisters from The Shining like a lot
of twins do it even though technically
the sisters in The Shining were not
twins cuz one was older than the other
um but I was like man if that I don't
think I've ever seen any twins like at a
horror convention or anything like that
they were dressed like the mantle twins
from dead ringers but if I did see that
I would just be like oh my God
that would be so [__] cool like
because I was thinking man I could do
that for Halloween one year but it's not
it's not the same if it's just one
person you know what I mean it kind of
has to be two people that look kind of
the same for it to really work
effectively I did make a shirt a while
back that had that said what did it say
on it I think it said mantle Brothers
Fertility clinic specializing in mutant
women and it had kind of like the two
guys with the red stuff on and like
weird tools and everything like that I
want to make a better version of it
though because I really like that idea
but um nobody steal that but yeah I did
make one like that I have one but one of
these days I'll do like a better design
cuz that one it looks pretty good but I
can do better but yeah so so this movie
Dreamland that came out in 2019 is kind
of like I don't even want to say it's
like a spiritual successor to ponti pool
because it's like I said it's not the
same story it's like a completely
spin-off fantasy I don't know if it's
any good or not I don't really hear
anybody talking about it um I might get
around to seeing it one of these days
even though it's technically I don't
think it's a horror movie I think it's a
fantasy but you know whatever close
enough now there has been talk since
2009 as far as I am aware that there is
going to be a direct sequel to ponti
pool which is called ponti pool changes
which is sort of what the book is called
the book is actually called ponti
changes everything um but yes but I
think this movie's been in development
like since they first started talking
about it in 2019 and there's updates on
it periodically like I think the last
one was maybe in 2019 it's it's like
yeah it's coming out next year but then
it never comes out so I don't know if
it's ever going to come out cuz like I
said there is something you could do
with this because at the end of ponci
pool you know they kind of imply that
they didn't really contain the virus
which you wouldn't really be able to if
this was a virus in real life so there
is somewhere you could go with that but
I don't
know um yeah Richard Brown said what
about the Twins and sisters that would
be good too it wouldn't I just feel like
it wouldn't be quite as recognizable you
know what I mean because it's not I mean
the obviously the twins from dead
ringers are that's very iconic like
those red like surgical scrubs that
they're wearing but the one if you're
talking about the um Brian De Palma
movie sisters with um Margo kit then I
can't really
remember I can't really remember that
any that either of them had like super
distinctive outfits that people would
immediately recognize cuz really the
only one like there's that one scene
where she's stabs the guy after he
brings her the birthday cake so you
could kind of put her like with crazy
hair and like kind of I think she had
pajamas on or like a night gown and like
a like a cake that said their names on
it but I can't think of what the other
normal one was
wearing well I don't want to give too
much away about that movie that's a
great movie if you've never seen it if
you like Brian deama came out in the 70s
it's weird as [__] I did I don't think
I've I don't remember if we've readen or
not but I wrote a big long thing about
it a long time ago like a big long essay
about it um yeah review of the signal
would be good says Danny because I don't
understand the ending even though I saw
it once yeah I really want to see it
again because I've only seen it one time
uh the signal and a wait further
instructions double bill would be cool
and paranoia inducing yeah cuz you know
what I haven't seen a wait further
instructions and I've been wanting to
watch that because I keep seeing it pop
up I think it's um it was either on shut
I think it kept popping up on shutter
and I was just kind of like man that
sounds good I need to watch that one of
these days and I just haven't got around
to it but you know that actually does
sound you know what I'm going to write
that down because maybe that'll be the
next thing I do I can do the signal and
I can do but wait further instructions
that would probably be
good and then because I haven't reviewed
either one of those and I have been
wanting to see them and I've been
wanting to do a rewatch on the signal
because I really like that movie uh a
carry cosplay should be easy as [__]
yeah I was
thinking I had um that WI that I had the
that red curly wig that I used for my um
Amy from Fright Night costume like for
Halloween while I was out and about I
was thinking to myself looking at myself
with that wig on and I said you know
what this wig would also work for Car's
mom and I was like and that would be
actually pretty easy you like the piper
Lori version like from the Brian of
Palma movie I was like all you need is
kind of like a moomoo type night gown
and then just like stick a bunch of
knives and forks and [__] like that in
there and then go around standed like
that like you're stuck to the wall I'm
like you know and maybe put like a
picture of Jesus behind her or something
like that but it's just kind of like cuz
that wig when I was looking at I was
like yeah it kind of looks like Amy's
Hair from Fright Night but I said it
looks more like Car's mom so maybe I'll
do that next year that' be super
easy that' be super easy I always think
of like all these really cool Halloween
costumes and then when Halloween comes I
was just like I don't know what I'm
going to do you know what I mean I ended
up doing Amy from Fright Night this year
cuz I already had all the [__] I didn't
have to buy anything else and and I had
worn it 3 years ago but I didn't go any
place you know what I mean so I figured
well I was going out this year so I said
well I'll wear it um let me see what
else uh ASD says I got docked on a point
dock a point on a book report in the
first grade because I forgot Sapphire
had two P's in it and I've been
motivated by Spite to be a vocabular
stop ever since see I feel you I feel
you on that and I get you know what and
this is really embarrassing and I've
heard like other people have the same
thing too and it's especially people
that are really really good that have
like a really big vocabulary but they
got it from
Reading like a lot when they were
younger so sometimes you've seen that
word you're familiar with that word but
you've never heard anybody say it out
loud so a lot of times if you try to use
it and you pronounce it wrong and then
because you've only ever seen it written
right it's like you know what that word
means though because you've seen it like
lots of times but you've never heard
anybody say it so just pronounce it like
in a way I can't I think I had a word
like that but I can't remember what it
is now cuz I remember being really
familiar with this word and thinking it
was pronounced one way and then like I
think I pronounced it wrong like and
somebody corrected me and I'm just kind
of like oh duh now I sound like an idiot
and I'm not an idiot I'm really not well
in some ways I'm an idiot but yeah yeah
Danny said a carry cosplay with visible
dirty pillows yeah I think a lot of
people do Carrie like because that's
pretty easy to do you just find like a
silky pink
ish prom dress and pour blood all over
yourself you know what I mean just put a
little TR on and that's you know I've
seen a lot of people at um horror
conventions with that I was thinking
about doing that this year too but I'm
like nah I'd have to buy a dress and
that's kind of a pain also another one I
want to do is the killer from Alice
Sweet Alice because all you need for
that is a yellow ring coat white tights
uh some little kind of Mary Jane type
shoes I think she had on
and um that mask that looks like a
that's clear but looks like it has
makeup on it and then like a big knife
Bob's your uncle and I and it'd be cool
because
that's Alice Sweet Alice it's not an
obscure movie but it's not super welln
so I feel like if you went to a horror
convention with that people would be
like ah you know what I mean oh my God
cuz I like to do original [__] I was
watching a super cut of like somebody
had made made like this hourong thing of
the best costumes from like different
horror conventions like big ones and
there were some really cool outfits one
of my favorite ones was somebody dressed
as judge Doom from Who Framed Roger
Rabbit and he had like the big barrel of
the dip and he was like putting the
little animated shoe in there and it was
it was it was great it looked really
good and like the [__] in the you know
the dip in the um the what the [__] is
it in the canister was like glowing and
[__] I'm just like oh my God that's
[__] brilliant like it was a pain in
the ass probably to carry that around
all day but it looked so [__] good
but then you had like 40 bajillion
people dressed like Pennywise you know
different versions of Pennywise it's
like you had a bunch of Jason's you had
a bunch of Freddy's you had a bunch of
Michael Myers you like and some people
like put different spins on it but I'm
still I'm just like still
eh I don't know I would just never do
that I would rather wear a costume that
99% of people said who the [__] are you
supposed to be then then wear something
that everybody else has on you know what
I mean because if you wear something
kind of obscure and there's that one
person at the conventions like oh my God
I know exactly what that's from then
you're going to be friends for life so
you see that's how that works out one of
these days too I wanted to be the chick
from Deon like at the end the fish lady
with the tentacles and the green and the
Gold Crown like with the
wheelchair that would be hard to do
though I need to make some tentacles and
need to make that Crown because it's not
like a a regular Crown you'd have to
make
it um Zach said can I do the accent I
probably could the car's mom yeah I
could do that I could do that
easy Bob we got us a reader
here it's a curse being the smartest
person in the
room I wouldn't know well I'm the
smartest person in this room cuz I'm the
only person in here right now so I guess
I could say that yes it is a a curse
it's it's very difficult yeah it was
called the dip wasn't it yeah I remember
when we went to see um Who Framed Roger
Rabbit when the hell did that come out '
87 88 something like
that um my family went to see it like we
all want to see it together and my
littlest my youngest brother who
was see it must have come out 87 or 88
cuz he was walking but he was still a
baby like he was still in diapers he was
like a toddler and we all went to see it
and when that happened the movie my
little brother whose name is Brian um he
jumped out of my mom's lap like when the
judge like put the put the shoe in the
dip he jumped out of my mom's lap and
his little diaper dash just ran all the
way out of the theater he was just like
nope he just noped right out I can't
blame the kid I mean he like I said he
was like two or something like that but
I still remember that and like the other
day like um I think last month or around
September like when I went to Disney and
upcot like with all my siblings I
reminded him about that he's like yeah I
remember I remember that and I was like
you just you were not having it you just
jumped right out of my mom's lap and
just
ran it was so funny Zach said you should
be Jessica Rabbit for Halloween I did
think about that but you know what when
we went to the Halloween party at
Barbarella there was a girl dressed like
jessic rabit there and so that would
have been very embarrassing if I'd
showed up
although this is going to sound kind of
mean I didn't know this girl but and I
didn't say it Tom did cuz this is some
[__] Tom would say he looks at the girl
and she's real pretty and everything
like that he's like she's too flat to be
just she's like she needs to not wear
that well it's like yeah she was really
pretty and everything but she was thin
and Jessica rabbit's whole thing is she
has like enormous bazongas so Tomas just
kind of like I don't think I would have
worn that costume if I was her he's like
he's like you should have done that you
have like bigger boot cuz you need kind
of big boobs to be Jessica Rabbit you
just do so I feel like if I was her you
can still be flat chest and be Jessica
Rabbit just wear fake ones I mean I
would because that's part of the costume
so if you don't have big boobs you just
got to like put fate ones on that's kind
of how that works um Dak says I heard a
story like that about Ari Aster when he
went to go see Dick Tracy as a kid I
don't remember much about Dick Tracy I
don't remember being scary but the thing
about it was that Roger Rabbit I mean
that was touted as a family film but it
was if you watch it now it's actually
pretty dark and the book that it was
based on was real dark so they lightened
it up some like for the movie but that's
another movie that I wanted to review I
don't like I don't even remember if th
has seen it maybe not I don't know I
really like ho and brj rabbit I've seen
it lots of
times yeah but it Dooms threatens to act
as execution or Riser rabbit with a
mixture of turpentine acetone and
Benzene he dubs the dip Doom showcases
the chemicals Purpose By killing a tune
shoe that really like and I was how old
was I when that movie came out I must
have been 16 I was a teenager and that
upset me too like CU I was like no he
was so cute and they killed him it was
like and I was just like oh that's
[__] up that's [__] up that's still
[__] up the 80s kids
movies were kind of messed up that's why
Generation X people are all
lunatics we're not lcts were just we're
troubled and damaged but that's I think
that's why because all the kids movies I
mean look at the [__] they made for kids
back then Gremlins The Witches Christ
man no wonder where all they messed up
yeah Ben said I saw cool world for the
first time a few months ago I remember
liking that but I haven't seen it in
I've seen it one time and it was a long
time ago and I hardly remember anything
about it cuz that was like a little mini
trend of live action mixed with
animation you know what I mean ASD says
on the topic of siblings and costumes
I'm still in the process of peer
pressuring my younger brother into
having a kid so I can borrow it for
Halloween and dress it up as a little
tub of the
stuff that would be [__] epic oh my
God that would be so
awesome actually that would be kind of a
good costume too if you could
somehow do um that part at the end which
was like stop motion where the where all
the stuff like comes out of the dude's
mouth and like his mouth is all big like
that that would be good
too but you that would you'd have to
really know what you were doing like to
do
that um yeah Isabella
said uh yeah it's excellent it still
looks great the effects are excellently
crafted I'm guessing you're talking
about Who Framed Roger Rabbit yeah I it
still holds up I
think and um yeah yeah Jessica Rabbit um
let me see babysick is like the stuff
yeah it is I don't have any kids myself
but I had three younger siblings many
many cousins and my parents ran a
daycare so I was around little kids all
the time which is one of the reasons
that I never wanted
any even though all of my siblings are
delightful and were when they were
children also they were all all really
good they weren't really a pain but
other people's kids were a huge pain in
the ass and I was just like yeah no not
for me not for me all right so how the
hell long holy crap I've been going on
for an hour it's at least Tom's not is
Tom watching me still are you watching
me still
Tom from the other room he's just like
in the he's in the bedroom and I'm in
the office I just thought that was so
funny that you popped in he was like
watching me making comments and stuff
but yeah so um I think I was pretty much
done talking about the movie um but yeah
it's on if you have shudder which you
should absolutely get I'm not sponsored
by shutter but I've had shutter for
years and years and I really really like
it some people piss and moan and they're
just like ah just get the free trial
over Halloween just watch what you want
to watch and then don't watch anymore
but I you know they add new [__] all the
time and it's I like that they have a
wide variety of things you know they
have a lot of old movies they have they
really keep up with new movies they have
a lot of foreign movies they have a lot
of series which I don't know if a lot of
people know um you know they had the new
Creep Show they had
uh what's the
um the drag brothers that's it's kind of
like that's a really cool show and they
also have um Joe Bob's Drive-In like
those are always fun but yeah so ponti
pool just got added to shudder it's
probably available elsewhere as well but
that's where I that was what reminded me
to do it because it just popped up and I
was like oh [__] I don't want to see
that so I decided to do it but yeah uh
so yeah check it out if you like zombie
movies and want to see something that's
kind
of a fresh take on it that's like I said
a little has maybe a little bit more of
a philosophical or an intellectual Edge
if you want to call it that cuz it's
kind of more like a radio drama it's not
like super not super action-packed in
the sense that you're just getting all
the information like through dialogue so
but I mean if that sounds like something
you would like then a lot of people
really do seem to like this movie and
you probably will like it too um but
yeah so I guess I'm going to wrap it up
for the afternoon uh remember to come by
tomorrow evening at 7:30 p.m. Eastern
Standard time for our regular show uh
with me and Tom obviously and we're
going to be talking about
man eating animals like I said we got
the idea
from that uh William Shatner show The
Unexplained that's
on Discovery TLC I don't remember what
it's on I watched it on Hulu so I don't
know what channel it started on but um
we watched like the season 4 of that
like all 26 episodes of it just like in
over three nights or whatever and they
did a episode about some manting animals
and I was like oh man that's a good idea
for a show so I put it in the poll and
it won so I was like oh goodie so we're
going to talk about the ghosts in the
darkness like those manting Lions we're
going to talk about that shark in New
Jersey that inspired Jaws um that Gustav
that big [__] crocodile who might be
still alive who's eaten like hundreds of
people which is [__] up that's that's
got to be one of the worst I don't want
to be eaten by either a shark or a
crocodile I don't want to be eaten by
any animal really but I think that would
be the worst with would be a shark or a
crocodile that' be so [__] up it's
just that kind of [__] gives me
nightmares so I'll probably add
nightmares after the show going to say
but it should be fun anyway uh but yeah
Tom's still here he's been watching me
the whole time now after I now after I
shut off he's probably going to like
critique I wonder if I'm going to go in
the room and he's going to critique my
performance or something like that oh
well I guess I better get on with it
yeah but um hopefully we'll see you guys
tomorrow night talking about man eting
animals and that'll do it for this movie
review I'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye